[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du journal sur tv 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 8 juillet voici les titres
de l'actualité locale
elle est officiellement ministre délégué
à la ville l'ex député des yvelines
nadia et a pris ses fonctions hier au
ministère de la cohésion des territoires
à paris cérémonie de passation avec son
prédécesseur julien de normandie après
avoir proposé du drive entend les
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines accueille du nouveau le public
une réouverture effective depuis hier
reportage à la médiathèque aimé-césaire
à la verrière et puis il fait bon les
vacances à la commanderie le lieu
multiculturel situe l encours organise
de nombreuses activités pour les 6-17
ans et jusqu'à la fin du mois de juillet
l épidémie ne cesse de progresser dans
le monde le coronavirus est également
toujours présents en france où la thèse
d'une deuxième vague prend même de
l'ampleur dans les yvelines un décès
supplémentaire a été enregistrés en 24
heures et les derniers chiffres sont en
légère hausse est 359 patients étaient
hospitalisés hier mardi sur le
territoire soit 2 de plus entre lundi et
mardi
vingt personnes étaient toujours placés
en réanimation une donnée inchangée en
ce début de semaine
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire de
1197 personnes ont été guéries de
lakovic 19 après un passage à l'hôpital
la passation de pouvoir a eu lieu hier
soir au ministère de la cohésion des
territoires à paris nadia est donc
officiellement devenu ministre délégué
en charge de la ville l ancien député
des yvelines succède à julien de
normandie retour sur la soirée des
images d'aurélie rond et le récit de
nicolas landry je te souhaite la
bienvenue au ministère de la cohésion
des territoires et des relations avec
les collectivités territoriales
nadia est accueilli par la ministre
jacqueline gourault pour sa prise de
fonction auprès d'elle yvelinoise
devient ministre délégué en charge de la
ville alors en place julien de normandie
qui rejoint le ministère de
l'agriculture
l'ex député de la 11e circonscription
des yvelines va s'occuper des zones
urbaines fortement impacté par la crise
sanitaire et les deux priorités
aujourd'hui sont évidemment l'emploi
parce qu'il faut que l'emploi que la
relance économique arrive dans ces
quartiers aussi et l'éducation parce que
cette période de confinement a eu un
effet très très grave dans la poursuite
scolaire des enfants
la politique de la ville sera au coeur
de son action une politique globale pour
lutter contre les inégalités sociales
dans les quartiers prioritaires avec
plusieurs dimensions culturelle sociale
économique ou encore éducative un sujet
de préoccupation dans plusieurs communes
de son ancienne circonscription
cette circonscription qui en fait en
réalité je lui dis tout le temps une
mini france parce que on part des
problématiques qui peuvent être des
problématiques rurales quand on est sur
la vallée de chevreuse avec la ville du
mesnil-saint-denis comme des
problématiques urbaines importantes
comme la ville de trappes d'action sera
orientée particulièrement sur les
quartiers politique de la ville mais
tous les territoires fragiles et surtout
surtout je le disais tout à l'heure
cette réconciliation entre le rural et
la ville
conséquence directe de sa nomination une
élection législative partielle va être
organisée dans les trois prochains mois
dans la 11e circonscription des yvelines
il est très clair que nous aurons un
candidat ou une candidate
la république en marge de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines pour rappel
lors du second tour des élections
législatives de 2010 est nadia et
l'avait emporté avec 52 96% devant le
candidat les républicains jean michel
fourgous et pour cette législative
partielle
un premier candidat nous vous en
parlions hier le conseiller municipal
d'opposition et élu régional
othman nasri philippe benassaya pourrait
être également en lice dans la 11e
circonscription le maire les
républicains de bois d'arcy est
intéressé par la fonction
et d'après nos confrères de 7,8 actu il
s'est dit candidat à la candidature un
comité départemental extraordinaire de
la fédération ait l'air et doit se tenir
ce jeudi pour désigner le candidat du
parti dans la circonscription à bois
d'arcy toujours le mystère plane à la
maison d'arrêt un détenu de 45 ans a été
retrouvé mort dans sa cellule dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche
l autopsie pratiquée sur son corps a
livré son verdict l'homme est morte des
suites d'une strangulation
une enquête est ouverte pour déterminer
s'il s'agit d'un suicide ou d'un meurtre
est la version de son co détenu
affirmant qu'il a chuté de son lit et ne
serait pas crédible
il sera de nouveau entendu par la sûreté
départementale des yvelines un autre
établissement carcéral la maison
centrale de poissy la députée des
yvelines florence granger a profité de
la séance de questions au gouvernement
aujourd'hui pour remettre son dossier au
nouveau ministre de la justice eric
dupond moretti
ils alertent sur la vétusté la
dangerosité des lieux rappelez-vous en
mars 2019 un mur extérieur du site
yvelinois s'était effondré est depuis le
maire de la ville karl olive milite pour
le déplacement de la maison centrale
hors du centre ville
le chantier a démarré aujourd'hui fermée
depuis 2012 la destruction du silo de
coignières a démarré les travaux
prendront environ deux mois avant de
faire place nette pour la construction
d'un nouveau parking à proximité des
habitations de la résidence des acacias
et du centre commercial coût de cette
démolition 400000 euros
elle les propos recueillis par mathilde
de 2 min c'est un peu paradoxal à un
silo qui contenait au départ 4 174
places de parking qu'on détruit pour
faire à la place des places de parking
voilà donc on aura une 70 places à peu
près de parking avec un aménagement
paysager ce qui va quand même vraiment
transformer la le quartier ça va errer
le quartier et ensuite en accord avec
séquences mais ça nous verrons en
septembre le plan d'aménagement
il y aura d'autres aménagements dans le
secteur qui seront effectuées sa liste
est arrivée en tête lors du second tour
des élections municipales à voisins le
bretonneux alexandra rosetti a été réélu
maire de la commune lors du conseil
d'installation samedi à 4 juillet elle
26 voix obtenues pour la maire sortante
de voix pour son opposante béatrice pira
et cinq bulletins blancs ce nouveau
conseil municipal devra notamment gérer
les problèmes de circulation de la ville
ainsi que la l'arrivée de la ligne 18 et
de son pôle égard est dans l'actualité
à saint quentin en yvelines également
les usagers des médiathèques ont pu
retrouver leurs lieux de lecture
certaines proposait déjà du drive depuis
quelques semaines mais hier mardi elles
ont rouvert totalement au public
les habitués étaient bien sûr au rendez
vous marylène yapi shiloh toucher les
livres les feuilleter et découvrir les
nouveautés pour faire son stock avant
les vacances c'est de nouveau possible
dans les médiathèques de saint quentin
en yvelines
le site aimé césaire à la verrière est
ouvert les mardis et vendredis de 15h à
18h tout le monde attendait quand même
de pouvoir renouveler le stock qu'ils
ont pu bien utilisé et consulté pendant
à la période de confinement donc on a eu
des appels quand même des adhérents ping
qui attendaient avec hâte et dès le
premier jour de réouverture mardi 7
juillet les adhérents étaient présents
heureux de pouvoir se plonger dans de
nouvelles histoires
j'ai essayé chercher dans les vieux
livres de mes parents mais après c'était
quand même moins bien que de trouver des
livres qui ne correspondaient quoi la
1ère fois je suis venu c'est en mars
2020 mes petits enfants
je leur prends régulièrement des livres
donc il attendait un petit peu fait
dérober le la biotech et regarder
régulièrement sous le site quand est-ce
que ça allait ouvrir pouvoir rentrer
dans la médiathèque
toucher les livres regarder les
nouveautés ça nous manquait beaucoup
quoi naturellement l'espace a été adapté
pour accueillir le public dans de bonnes
conditions sanitaires du gel hydro
alcoolique est à disposition et les
salles de travail et espace bébés ne
sont pas encore accessibles
on ne peut venir quand on veut pour
rendre et emprunter des documents
on peut de nouveau faire des
réservations sur tout le réseau comme on
faisait avant par contre effectivement
il faut porter un masque à partir de 12
ans la médiathèque aimé césaire restera
exceptionnellement ouverte tout l'été
de quoi s'évader même en restant à la
maison il ya bientôt deux mois nous
sortions de huit semaines de confinement
imposées par la crise sanitaire une
période difficile pour beaucoup une
source aussi d'inspiration pour d'autres
les yvelinois et de jolies prod en ont
profité pour réaliser un court métrage
ça s'appelle confinement intime c'est
disponible sur youtube le film
questionne notamment sur les la liberté
les notions de liberté de vie privée
pour en parler julien denervaud et
frédéric landat bonsoir bon ça on ça
alors julien denervaud à jolie prof vous
êtes vice président à la direction
artistique et sur ce court métrage vous
occuper la fonction de coréalisateur et
coscénariste est aussi acteur et on vous
voit dans ce court métrage et frédéric
landat vous êtes trésorier de jolis prod
et acteur dans confinement intime une
précision cela et a été tourné
entièrement à distance comme notre
interview
ce soir dans le journal je vous propose
qu'on regarde tout de suite en extrait
comité où la table à cartes dans notre
chambre sort de la catherine n'ont pas
pas sinon ils vont pas me trouver
sors de là bordaises je te laisse
oui bonjour papa tient au avignon à
clermont ferrand
pas drôle que tu sois commencé là-bas
pendant le continent tu sais où tu as
mère que je n'ai pas entendu des films
dans le placard de notre chambre va la
chercher s'il te plait je vais la
chercher des extraits de confinement
intime un court métrage tourné je le
disais entièrement à distance déjà une
première question comment vous est venue
l'idée pendant le confinement de
réaliser ce court métrage
bon alors c'est très simple en fait
pendant le confinement il ya un moment
donné ça nous a manqué de pas nous voir
d'habitude on se voit régulièrement fait
plein de projets artistiques autour du
cinéma du théâtre de la musique bref
énormément de choses et là on s'est dit
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
on a une envie commune de créer et on a
des choses à dire par rapport à la
liberté la vie privée l'intimité des
gens avec toute cette place de la
technologie
aujourd'hui enfin la place qu'elle prend
dans notre société est acquis c'est
encore plus accentuée avec ce
confinement et les visioconférences dont
on s'est dit qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
on a eu plein d'idées avec tous les
jolis producteurs et toutes les jolies
productrice on a mis tous ses idées
ensemble et ensuite on s'est lancé dans
l'écriture d'un scénario avec olivier
salazar qui a fait un premier jet et
ensuite qui a été et bien amélioré et
continuer avec salomé carsen claire
soudier et moi-même et de là on s'est
dit bon bah maintenant on part là dessus
et on va se faire un film pendant le
confinement et qu'on sortira à la fin du
confinement et ce travail à distance
frédérick e ça n'a pas été trop
difficile de pouvoir tous vos
coordonnées pour pour ce court métrage
bat déjà on peut dire que c'est déjà une
performance artistique jeu durant ce
tournage en fait on a été un as tu géré
en fait le côté activé le côté et le
côté technique on était un peu livré
tout seul en un tonneau me donc moi
c'était vrai après on a vraiment
s'inquiéter
tu t'es vraiment une performance pure et
crème confirmez vous avez dû vous même
vous cadrez
faire le preneur de sons en fait gérés
tout l'aspect technique depuis chez vous
directement c'est ça on a géré la
lumière on a géré le plan ont nagé le
son client puisse après à côté on avait
notre notre caste aussi à à bien s'en
rend bien à bien récitée pour pour les
séquences et puis après je peux aussi
ajouter que on a tourné en plan séquence
donc en fait c'est le plan séquence en
fait dans le cinéma c'est c'est une
scène où on coupe à la caméra pendant
tout le long et il faut savoir que si
jamais le on a une moindre petite erreur
ou un objet de recommencer la séquence
juste depuis le début c'est quelque
chose quand même de deux complices y est
on a aussi très bien de halleux à le
faire à distance ce julien avec les
moyens du bord ça a été tournée on le
voit sur sur des images à la webcam
téléphones tablettes
on le disait des acteurs aussi multi
casquettes c'est toute une réflexion
qu'il a fallu avoir en tant que co
réalisateur une ré nouvelle réflexion
sur la manière de faire ce court métrage
c'est ça il ya vraiment là par rapport à
la coordination à cette réflexion la
réflexion à la fois sur le fond du film
quel message on va faire passer et sur
tout l'aspect technique comme le
souligne fred à l'instant ben voilà
c'est que de la visioconférence tout le
monde imagine la visioconférence qui l'a
fait pendant le confinement avec sa
famille ou avec son travail en
télétravail etc
c'est des choses qui prennent un peu la
tête des fois au bout d'une heure de
réunion en conférence c'est pas la même
chose qu'en physique est là il faut
imaginer que c'est des réunions pendant
depuis fin mars avec un tournage début
mai donc que des réunions en
visioconférence et un tournage 24 enfin
de 8h à 22h le soir en visioconférence
donc pour diriger les acteurs c'est
compliqué ou dans l'énergie pour la
faire passer ces shows en termes
d'actifs
puisque les acteurs ne se voit pas ne
peuvent pas se renvoyer de l'énergie
physiquement ils font juste s'entendre
par des oreillettes
voilà donc il ya toute une logistique et
mise en place derrière c'est pour ça
qu'on parle de performances artistiques
aujourd'hui en termes de la création
puisque devient un délai très court
il ya des moyens très réduit puisque ça
nous a coûté 0 1 par électricité de chez
nous et notre
annette et de quoi est il question alors
on l'a compris ça parle du confinement
bien sur ce court métrage mais quel est
le le synopsis c'est très drôle le
synopsis on peut pas vraiment dire je
pense pour regarder le film pour pour
savoir de quoi ça parle
en revanche il faut bien avoir en tête
que l'histoire est un prétexte au film
vous avez le concept du film avec la
volonté les messages qui a derrière et
cette histoire
en gros le téléspectateur va être
embarqué dans une histoire et la fin
sera interprété par chacun et chacun
veut être libre d'interpréter de la
manière qu'ils le souhaitent ce film est
de comprendre les choses qu'il veut en
comprendre mais il ya énormément de sous
texte autour de la vie privée et de
l'intimité de la liberté la place de la
technologie aujourd'hui du confinement
on a aussi deux dents une téléréalité
qui a été faite par alexandre pidoux et
florine célestin qui étaient confinés
ensemble c'est un groupe et on a joué
sur ce parallèle avec la télé réalité où
les gens vont s'enfermer volontairement
voilà il se confine volontairement dans
un endroit à la recherche de la
notoriété
aujourd'hui nous on s'est tous retrouvés
confiné involontairement pour se
protéger donc du coup il ya ce parallèle
la et et tous et double personnalité
avec des gens dans les réseaux sociaux
etc
voilà je vous laisse voir le film parce
que c'est à vous de vous faire votre
propre interprétation avec tous les
codes notamment la télé réalité on les
voit notamment s'engueuler mais oui
c'est vrai il faut il faut regarder ce
court métrage le tout d'ailleurs avec le
prisme de la webcam on peut le dire ça a
été un petit peu notre meilleur ami
pendant le confinement c'était notre
lien avec la famille les proches
oui totalement c'était c'était c'était
un lien avec tout le monde et là ça a
été en plus nous notre lien social parce
que entre nonce côtoie régulièrement
très souvent et donc là la première idée
qui nous est venue sebha ok on en visio
même nom créé quelque chose et donc on
va créer quelque chose autour de la
visioconférence toujours dans l'esprit
jolie prod donc un joli film avec un
joli scénario est bas dans une jolie
ambiance
voilà donc malgré les difficultés
techniques qu'on a pu rencontrer avec
coupure d'internet orages qui empêche la
connexion etc
on y reste
dans une jolie ambiance pendant tout le
tournage et une bienveillance et
d'ailleurs je remercie au passage toute
l'équipe d'avoir tenu parce que c'était
pas facile et on a réussi quoi faire
cette performance je vois qu'ils
essaient frédéric oui là c'était une
bonne c'était de la bonne ambiance sur
sur ce projet abbas était une voix s'est
tue c'est une bonne ambiance et puis une
façon de faire un court métrage match
est différent par rapport au précédent
qu'on a pu réaliser auparavant
donc bonne ambiance et bonne expérience
avec très rapidement julien une
dimension yvelinoise la musique est
proposé par un groupe de rambouillet oui
c'est sa part le groupe glisse river
donc c'est un duo de musiciens
compositeurs
il compose notamment de la musique un
peu pour le cinéma et autres ils sont en
préparation de leur album avec et jolie
preuve ce sont des jeux les producteurs
celui des augustes river on a pu le
retrouver sur notre jolie soirée concert
à l'année dernière à m as à voisins le
bretonneux
donc il ya toute cette dimension est ce
ce maillage tout ce réseau constitue
concret avec jolie prod et que l'on
cherche à développer pour développer les
talents locaux
on le retrouve aussi à travers ce court
métrage et et puis bah oui cette musique
là c'est un extrait que c'est de leur
musique human on a été choisi un extrait
de la musique et ça colle parfaitement
avec le film donc merci encore un studio
nous y sert à réguler skriver allez le
voir ce court métrage ça s'appelle
confinement intime c'est disponible sur
youtube et aussi pour retrouver toute
l'actualité de jolis prod vous invite à
vous rendre sur le site internet le lien
également s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci à vous deux julien et et frédéric
d'avoir été avec nous merci pour moi
c'est un plaisir pour ce court métrage
confinement intime de jolis prod
on parle toujours cinéma avec nos
visites hebdomadaires dans les salles du
territoire yvelinois direction ce soir
l'ugc ciné-cité skywest à montigny le
bretonneux qui proposera une
avant-première dimanche son directeur en
parle au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude
j'invite tous nos clients de saint
quentin on fera une avant première le
dimanche 12 juillet prochain à 16h15
pour le film tout simplement noir qu'on
aura en avant première par avec les
marées noires ça je vends de l'afrique
dont marne et montreuil un peu tout cela
il est temps qu'il sorte la terre natale
est rentré il même peu de conscience
même peu de faux mais un peu de maturité
c'est tout ça va c'est pas le rappeur
préféré des collégiens qui doit me
donner des leçons drap tendu des films
de kung pixels il a pas tort de pas peur
[Musique]
la crise sanitaire pousse les
associations a rivalisé d'imagination la
voie en scène a par exemple profiter du
confinement pour créer des live est le
but entendre les talents découverts par
l'association mais aussi en découvrir de
nouveaux avec en ligne de mire le
tremplin des voix concours dont les
candidatures sont lancés à la mi-juillet
mélanie poké 15 et messieurs bonsoir
bienvenue dans la quinzième émissions
des warner je continuais à découvrir des
talents s'amuser tout en chantant
pendant le confinement la voie en scène
créé un talk un live de près de deux
heures il y a donc si six candidats
sélectionnés par le public
donc le public vote les candidats en
fait envoient leurs leur vidéo par
internet par par les réseaux sociaux
donc instagram donc le public vote
et puis ceux qui sont sélectionnés passe
sur le live du mercredi et puis on a un
ou deux invités le soir et deux
professionnels invités avec moi ça fait
3 animé pendant deux jours pendant le
confinement l'émission a gardé un numéro
hebdomadaire depuis le 11 mai l'occasion
aussi pour les organisateurs de lancer
le prochain tremplin des voix le sixième
trois auditions
deux auditions donc une audition à magny
les hameaux le 14 novembre
une audition à paris
aux alentours du 21 au 28 novembre ça
reste à définir et une audition à la
réunion à l'île de la réunion le 12
décembre normalement si tout va bien
elle les inscriptions pour le tremplin
seront ouvertes le 15 juillet prochain
les voix aux nerfs continue
prochain rendez vous ce mercredi 8
juillet et des concerts à distance vous
venez de le voir dans ce reportage mais
aussi des galas de danse en virtuel
c'est à saint cyr l'école que ça se
passe il était organisé par saint cyr
danse le week-end dernier 150 élèves de
l'association ont enregistré une
chorégraphie qui a été diffusée à toutes
les familles vendredi et dimanche
elle est licenciée ont ainsi pu
présenter le travail réalisé pendant
l'année et notamment pendant le
confinement le gala dure 45 minutes
regardez cet extrait
[Musique]
vous
oh
et puis jusqu'au 31 juillet la
commanderie vit à l'heure des vacances
le site multiculturel de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines installé à
elancourt propose de nombreuses
activités pour les jeunes de 6 à 17 ans
le reportage de mélanie poquet les
secrets des couleurs ne le sont plus
pour ces jeunes peintres en herbe ses
enfants explorent depuis lundi cet
univers artistiques et scientifiques
vers la fin il me demande de regarder
les couleurs contre se mélanger avec les
couleurs primaires
maj que j'ai trouvé c'est vert orange et
violet est en train de mélanger des
couleurs primaires avec les secondaires
et on a mélangé le jaune avec leur
hausse
ça fait du orange a pris le plus avec le
jaune du vert
animé par l'artiste plasticienne en
résidence ma flow est pas doué ce stage
est inscrit dans le programme estival de
la commanderie
un rendez vous destiné aux enfants de 6
à 17 ans on est quatre ans mission
installer ici
et l'idée c'est qu'on propose aussi au
public de traverser tous les genres
qu'on défend à la commanderie
les enfants sont vraiment en immersion
et c'est ce qui nous intéresse aussi
dans ce projet de c'est les vacances
c'est que les enfants soient en
immersion toute la journée avec
l'artiste avec l'intervenant est avec
ses petits copains de l'atelier autres
salles de stage et autre ambiance ici
les jeunes se transforment en
scientifique il découvre que
l'électricité ce n'est pas que de la
magie je compte essayer de leur faire
fabriquer un condensateur pouvoir
réaliser des petites étincelles avec un
condensateur
pourquoi pas on va travailler sur un
système de
des transmissions de son par laser
l'idée c'est de transmettre le son grâce
à du laser et grâce à la lumière en
général jusqu'au 31 juillet dix ateliers
sont programmés au sein de la
commanderie de la danse de la nature et
de la lecture
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité très belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]